in the third cause of this sequence of
five causes you saw how error analysis
can help you focus your time on doing
the most useful work for your project
now beam search is an approximate search
algorithm also called a heuristic search
algorithm and so it doesn't always
output the most likely sentence as only
keeping track of B equals 3 or 10 or 100
top possibilities so what a beam search
makes a mistake in this video you
learned how error analysis interacts
with beam search and how you can figure
out whether it is the beam search
algorithm that's causing problems and
worth spending time on or whether it
might be your RNN model that is causing
problems that were spending time on
let's take a look at how to do error
analysis wood beam search let's use this
example of Jane Vizio free concept on so
let's say that in your machine
translation Jeff said your development
said the human provided this translation
and Jane visits Africa in September and
I'm going to call this y star so there's
a pretty good translation written by a
human but let's say that when you run
beam search on your learned RNN model on
your learn translation model it ends up
with this translation who thought why
hat Jane this is Africa lost September
which is a much worse translation of the
French sentence that she changes the
meaning this is not a Greek translation
now your model has two main components
there is a neural network model the
sequence the sequence model which
numbers is called that's your RNN model
it's really an encoder and a decoder and
you have your beam search offer from
which you're running with some B with B
and wanna be nice if we could attribute
this error there's not very good
translation to one of these two
components was it the RNN or really the
neural network that is more to blame or
is it the beam search offer that is more
to blame and what you saw in the third
cause of the sequence is that is always
10th
to collect more training days er that
never hurts so similar way is always
tempting to increase the beam work you
know that never hurts so it pretty much
never hurts
but just as getting more training data
by itself might not to get you to the
level performance you want in the same
way increasing the beam width by itself
might not get you to where you want to
go and so but how do you decide whether
or not improving the search algorithm is
a good use of your time so kids now you
can break the problem down and figure
out what's actually a good use of your
time
now the RNN via the neural network
opposed to call RNN breathing is the
encoder and the decoder it computes P of
Y given X so for example for a sentence
Jane visits Africa in September you plug
in Jane visits Africa again I'm ignoring
upper versus lower case for now right
and so on and this computes P of Y given
X so it turns out that the most useful
thing for you to do at this point this
is compute using this model to compute P
of Y star given X as well as to compute
P of Y hat given X using your own hand
model and then to see which of these two
is bigger so it's possible that the left
side is bigger than the right hand side
it's also possible that P of Y star is
less than P my have actually less than
an equal zero depending on which of
these two cases hold true you'd be able
to more clearly ascribe this particular
error disprove the back translation to
one of the RNN or the beam search
algorithm being at greater fault so
let's figure out the logic behind this
here are the two sentences from the
previous slide and remember we're going
to compute P of Y star given X and P of
Y hat give an X and see which of these
two and see which of these two is bigger
so they're going to be two cases in case
one P of Y star given X as output by the
RNN model
this greater than P of Y hat given X
what does this mean well the beam search
algorithm chose Y hat right the way you
got Y hat was you had an RNN there was
computing P of Y given X and beam says
job was to try to find the value of y
that gives that Outbacks
but in this case y star actually attains
a higher value for P of Y given X dent
in Y hat so what this allows you to
conclude is beam search is failing to
actually give you the value of y that
maximizes P of Y given X because you
know the one job that beam search had
was to find the value of y that makes us
really big but it shows y hat but y star
actually gets a much bigger value so in
this case you could conclude that beam
search is at fault now how about the
other case in case two P of Y star given
X is less than or equal to P or Y hat
given X and then you know either this or
this has got to be true so either case
one or case two has a whole troupe what
you conclude under case two
well in our example y star is a better
translation than Y hat but according to
the RNN P of Y star is less than pure Y
hat so saying that Y stars are less
likely output than Y hat so in this case
it seems that the RNN model is at fault
and it might be worth spending more time
working on the RNN there's some
subtleties here
pertaining to length normalizations and
I'm glossing over if there's some
subtleties pertaining to length
normalization I'm glossing over and if
you are using some sort of length
normalization instead of evaluating
these probabilities you should be
evaluating the optimization objective
that takes an account length
normalization
but ignoring that complication for now
in this case was it tells you is that
even though Y star is a better
translation the RNN astride y star a
lower probability than the inferior
translation so in this case I would say
the RNN model is at fault
so the error analysis process looks as
follows you'd go through the development
set and find the mistakes that the avram
aid in development set and so in this
example let's say that P of Y given X
was 2 by 10 to the minus 10 whereas pier
y had given X was 1 by 10 to the minus
10 using the logic from the previous
slide in this case we see that beam
search actually chose Y hat which has a
lower probability than y star so I would
say beam search is at fault so that
really that be and then you go through a
second mistake or second Battal point by
the algorithm
look at these probabilities and maybe
for the second example
you think the model is that for Eevee
the RNN model with R and you go through
more examples and sometimes the beam
searches that fault sometimes even
models at fault and so on and through
this process you can then carry out
error analysis to figure out what
fraction of errors are due to beam
search versus the RNN model and with an
error analysis process like this for
every example in your depth set where
the algorithm gives a much worse example
where the algorithm gives a much worse
output than the human translation you
can try to describe the error to either
the search algorithm or to the objective
function or to the RNN model that
generates the objective function that
beam search is supposed to be maximizing
and through this you can try to figure
out which of these components is
responsible for more errors and only if
you find that beam search is responsible
for a lot of errors then maybe it's
worth working hard to
is to be with whereas in contrast if you
find that the RNN model is at fault then
you could do a deeper layer of analysis
to try to figure out if you want to add
regularization or get more training data
or try different network architecture or
something else and so a lot of the
techniques that you saw in the third
course in the third course in this
sequence would be applicable there so
that's it for error analysis using beam
search I found this for clear error
analysis process very useful whenever
you have a approximate optimization
algorithm such as beam search that is
working to optimize some sort of
objective some sort of cost function
that is output by a learning algorithm
such as the sequence the sequence model
see one sequence RNN that we've been
discussing in these lectures so with
that I hope that you'd be more efficient
at making these types of models work
well for your applications